U.S House speaker Nancy Pelosi flew from
Washington to San Francisco on Friday to
join her husband after his emergency
surgery
police say an intruder broke into the
family home and attacked 82-year-old
Paul Pelosi our officers observed Mitch
Pelosi and a suspect both holding a
hammer
the suspect pulled the hammer away from
Miss Pelosi and violently assaulted him
with it our officers immediately tackled
the suspect disarmed him took him into
custody requested emergency backup and
rendered Medical Aid Paul Pelosi
suffered a fractured skull and injuries
to his right arm and hands the suspect
42-year-old David depopy has been
charged with attempted homicide so far
no motive but numerous Reports say the
suspect screamed where is Nancy where is
Nancy during the incident
those words echo images from the January
6th attack on the U.S Capitol when some
Trump supporters broke into Nancy
Pelosi's office intent on finding her it
also brings to mind other recent efforts
to harm government officials including
the shooting at a baseball field in June
2017 which left Republican
representative Steve scalise fighting
for his life
Pelosi is second in line to the
presidency so she has round-the-clock
security however her family and other
Congressional families do not and we're
going to end crazy
the vice president caught the attack on
Paul Pelosi the result of demagoguery
there is so much
discourse that is fueled by hate and
Division
and anyone who professes to be a leader
I think has to really
understand the the meaning and the and
the impact of their words and their
posture on things like this the
president echoed Harris's remarks this
is Despicable
there's no place in America
there's too much violence political
violence
too much hatred
too much vitriol
at a time of heightened anti-politician
feeling in the U.S translating concern
into action will be a challenge Rosalind
Jordan Al Jazeera